[Music]
Hi everybody. I'm Bobby. This is Cam.
And uh we're both engineers here at
OPZero. and we've both been working a
lot in this uh the AI space lately um
trying to come up with clear ways for
identity and access control that's
designed for a world where agents are
center stage. So that's included our
work on our oforgi platform, our ozero
mcp server and our own firstparty agent
called tenant security manager. And just
like everyone here, we're learning from
the community as well as we do this.
just the main thing is trying to get to
grips with what delegation and access
means in a world where agents are acting
on users behalf. Um and today we want to
share some of those lessons that we've
learned in this journey. And um what's
actually worked, what hasn't worked, and
a few practical ways that you can get
started with identity and access right
from the start.
But uh I had to splash this slide
because we were show we were told we
could have opinions as long as we showed
it. So here we go. To kick things off,
let's talk about uh the security
challenges of smarter agents. Um as they
start to do more things in the real
world and once they're moving behind
beyond chat and actually doing things in
the in the real world cracks are
starting to appear and it's pretty clear
secrets end up in prompts, scopes get
too broad and troubleshooting gets
really really hard when you don't have
the right visibility. So agents are out
there making decisions, taking actions
on behalf of users, but it's very easy
to lose track of what's really going on.
Uh things might look fine on the
surface, right up until there's a
security incident and you realize you
don't have enough data to trace what
actually happened.
This is where a lot of the genai risks
begin. The OASP OASP calls it excessive
agency, but really that's just a fancy
way of saying giving agents too much
access without guardrails. And access
here means calling APIs, pulling data,
using tokens, touching credentials and
keys. If that access isn't scoped,
monitored, and tied to a real user,
you're wide open to abuse and unintended
behavior. And there's other OASP risks,
too, like sensitive data exposure. But
that often comes back to the same root
cause. If a agent reaches into something
they shouldn't, it's usually because no
one told it not to. And if you've been
listening to the talks here, it's pretty
clear that agents aren't just responding
to prompts anymore. They're actually
doing real things, calling APIs, kicking
off workflows, changing your systems.
And that means they're moving through
your stack, touching real user data,
interacting with real external systems.
And it all needs to happen under the
right context. Not just on behalf of
your app, but on behalf of your users,
individuals.
Here's what this looks like in practice.
Uh on the left, you see a pattern that's
very common. And an agent calling an API
using a shared uh key pulled from an
environmental variable. Um that key
probably gets reused across users,
environments, maybe even different
services. It works, but it's fragile.
You can't tell who did what and rotating
uh secrets and keys is manual and risky
and the axis is way too broad. On the
right, things are looking better.
Instead of a shared static key, the
agent asks your backend for a token
that's just for the one user and one
API. The backend uses something like
token exchange to hand out shortlived
token and the agent can safely use that.
Now you've got a real record of who did
what and you can easily rotate tokens,
support multiple upstream systems and
manage up uh all this in a centralized
way. And we've seen that this approach
scales much better even if you have
dozens or hundreds of agents. It's a
small tweak in your flow, but a big step
up in how you handle risk.
So we've talked about the secrets and
shared credentials problem, but
underneath it all is identity. If your
agent doesn't have identity, it doesn't
matter how well you scope your tokens or
rotate tokens, you still have don't have
real control here. And identity is what
connects actions to users. It lets you
understand what happened, trace the
activity, and decide what should happen
next. But before we talk about
delegation and scope, we need to get
identity right. So if identity is the
part we're often missing, the next
question is who's the agent actually
working for? If you don't have a clear
answer, chances are it's just running as
a service account. And that's how you
get the confused deputy problem that
you've been hearing a lot about uh this
week. The agent has access, but it
doesn't know who it's acting for, what
it should avoid. The fix is to anchor
that behavior into real users using
standard flows like OOTH 2.1, RAR, uh,
and token exchange to tightly control
what the agent can do. um that includes
refreshing tokens properly properly and
preserving upstream identity. And here's
how it works in practice. When an agent
needs to act, it doesn't grab a key from
a static config. Instead, it uh asks
your backend for help. The backend
reaches into a vault, fetches a
credential, and uses token exchange to
uh to to mint a token that's shortlived
just for this user and API. That token
never sits with the agent. It's handed
off, used, and gone. And this keeps your
agent focused on doing its job, not
carrying around secrets. And it lines up
with familiar OASH standards. So you're
not inventing the wheel, which you
should never do with identity. And let's
shift gears now to the rag systems. When
you're using rag, you're not just
handing data to the model. You're making
choices about what it sees. And not
every user should unlock the same data
context. This is where fine grain
authorization matters. You don't want
the agent deciding access inside your
LLM. You want that enforced much earlier
at the retrieval layer where policy
enforcement enforcement can kick in. So
you want to do this so that none of your
sensitive data leaks out and you keep
your company and your users secure. Um
early we covered how to scope access
which agent can see. But sometimes
that's not enough. You also need to
control when and how that access is
provisioned. That's where client
initiated back channel authentication
which is a mouthful or SIBA comes in.
Instead of showing a UI, the agent sends
a request to the authorization server.
The server reaches out to the user on a
trusted device via something like a push
notification and then the user decides
whether to approve, deny, or ask for
more information. Um, this pattern is
really great for agents running in the
background or in scenarios where there's
no screen to direct a user to. And Cam's
going to show the demo where this really
comes to life. So, keep this flow in the
back of your mind when you see that. And
of course, we can't talk about secure
agent execution without talking about
MCP. Um, MCP servers are showing up
everywhere these days. What started as
local standard IO input on your on your
laptop is quickly turning into a core
part of remote distributed systems. And
once you put it on the network, security
can't be an afterthought. This pattern
here uses um OOTH 2.1 flow. The user
signs in through the browser. MCP server
handles the token minting behind the
scenes. Agent gets scoped and bound up
front and the token is issued. Client
never exposes thirdparty credentials.
The key takeaway is that when every tool
in action runs on a shared server, the
need for solid guarantees about who's
making each request and doing what
they're actually doing becomes critical.
All right. So to bring this all
together, Cam's going to show what this
looks like in practice. He's going to go
through the the SIBA flow and example.
Cam, over to you. Sweet. Thanks, Bobby.
Um, a lot of talking points. This is not
going to be a challenging demo. Uh, so
thanks for outlining some of the uh
security and identity challenges that
are facing production grade uh API agent
or AI agents. Building on that overview,
um you can actually find this demo uh
alongside of a ton of other really great
working demos um at the following URL
that I've got highlighted in the
package. JSON of this little
application. Um, for our scenario, we're
going to do a a local AI trading
assistant that's going to make local
tool calls to a broker service in order
to buy stock, right? Uh, we tried to
make this as applicable as possible. Uh,
the AI agent is going to initiate the
request, but the user is going to have
to explicitly approve it before uh, it's
executed. I don't have enough screen, so
I'm going to pull another one up. This
will be really fun. Bear with me. All
right. So, um, this is going to really,
um, emphasize three critical components
for us. So we're going to have user
identification and context which is
going to identify the user so that the
agent can act on their behalf. Uh we're
going to use the token vault to prevent
us from embedding any kind of like you
know secrets or uh sensitive data inside
of our actual code. And then we're going
to use SIBA or client initiated back
channel authentication uh to request
user consent before the agent executes
sensitive actions. It's worth
highlighting uh this is going to require
an identity provider that supports SIBA.
Um you know our Ozero is the company we
work for. Um but importantly like SIBO
is part of the OIDC specification. So
this is going to become more ubiquitous
over time. Uh so taking a look at the
app that's driving this demo. Um
zoom out a couple here. Cattle love
Intelligj. I'm gonna hide this too.
There we go. Okay. So we're using a
pretty simple TypeScript CLI
application. Anybody speak TypeScript in
the room? Show of hands. Few. Okay. All
right. Uh the Python demo will come
later. Um so um this is basically just
going to expose a command line interface
on uh for the user uh which is
configured with a stock trading um tool.
Let me make sure that a couple of
prerexs that I need are true.
Bear with me one second.
All right. Um I do not see what I'm
looking for,
but that should be fine hopefully. Um so
um rolling back um in a more mature
mature trading environment it would
probably look something like this. Um so
you'll have this user who's going to
specify you know buy some stock um at a
certain threshold which will get
dispensed as a user action that'll
interface with your um chatbot. there'd
be some sort of polling system that
would be capable of understanding what
like the real-time value of that stock
trade is over time and then it would um
at the time where whatever threshold is
defined at that point it would then
execute the trade and prior to executing
the trade it would dispatch a SIBO
request to make sure that the user is
able to authenticate that right at the
at the last mile. Um now with today's
stock volatility being what it is, it'd
be a real challenge to define any
reliable trade rule based on vibes and
truth social posts. So we're going to
allide certain elements of this stack.
That was a joke. I hope you enjoyed
that. Um, let's stay on the script now.
Um, so we're going to take a look at the
actual application. So this is the
primary agent configuration and runtime
definition. Um, inside of this stack,
you can see it's bifurcated into two
primary methods. You've got the generate
messages method, which is basically the
handler that's interfacing between the
LLM and the user. Here we're passing in
this buy tool, which we're going to dig
into a little bit more. Um, then
subsequent to that, you have the main
method, which is going to run on the
main thread. Here's where we're going to
define the context and bind it to a
particular thread for this particular
session. This is going to give us the
ability to um durably identify who uh
who is using this particular um uh
session.
Um so within that let's take a look at
the actual tool call. Um so here we have
the definition of a tool call and uh
this application u you'll note that it's
wrapped in two higher order component uh
functions. So there's this use device
flow. taking a look at that. Um, this is
basically how it is um that we are uh
bootstrapping the OIDC uh wrapper within
this application. That's going to enable
us to have an OC client bootstrap for
the application. This enables me to use
access tokens on behalf of a user
basically. So there's a whole lot of
configuration that goes into that.
Stepping back, there's another handler
this use SBA um I order component. So
this is basically going to enable um
this application to um intercept a tool
call in which we want the user to be
able to approve or deny behavior and
that's really the heart of SIBA. It's
also where we provide configuration
information to our identity provider
about how we're going to use the
resources. So in our case we're using a
blocking call back down here um which is
going to um actually pause the
application while it's running in order
to wait for the approval. Um, you could
wire this up with an asynchronous flow
or polling or however you wanted to. Um,
but for the sake of this demo, this was
a lot easier. Uh, one last thing that
I'll highlight here, uh, inside of the
buy tool call, uh, the way that we're
handling credentials here on line 28.
Um, this prevents us from embedding, um,
client secrets directly inside of the
code, which is a nice utility, uh,
method in Ozero. We call this our token
vault. Uh, it's dissimilar from like um,
like one password or like a credential
manager. This is managing tokens, not
credentials. So, just a little bit of a
note there. So, let's get these services
running. Uh, fingers crossed we don't
run into uh any super fun Wi-Fi issues.
May the Wi-Fi gods be forever on our
side as that comes up. Um, so even with
local AI agents, identity matters,
especially when you're using um multiple
users with multiple agents involved um
or if the agent has access to, you know,
user data or user files, right? So, it's
crucial to know who the um who is
interacting with what and at what time.
uh especially like once compliance gets
into this, it gets a lot more um robust.
So, we're uh not using a fully stateful
service to preserve and persist the
user's identity. Um so, instead, we're
going to authenticate the user through
the UI. So, you'll notice that um little
blurb will pop up. After that, when the
AI agent needs to perform a sensitive
action like executing a trade, we're
going to rely on SIBA. That means no
additional userfacing UI is required
after the user has given us their
tokens. And I'll give you a little bit
of a demo of that. So we're definitely
aware that identity standards like OOTH
2, OIDC, SIBA, these are not always top
of mind or super interesting for
developers when you're building great
applications. That's why we're
highlighting that there are solutions to
these problems. There's open standards
that are evolving over time. Um and a
lot of those are live today. Um so that
can be something to be thought of uh in
the progenation of an application
instead of as an afterthought. So one
thing that we run into repeatedly while
building this demo is determining just
how much complexity is needed to
effectively showcase um you know these
sorts of scenarios. Um, please let us
know how we struck that balance. Uh, you
can email Bobby directly. Uh, he loves
feedback. All right. Uh, so now for the
fun part. Let's try and buy some stocks
with this. Uh, if the Wi-Fi gods are on
our side. So, um, buy me 10 stocks
of SECO, just some company. So, what
this is going to do, um, is the LLM is
going to process the intent and it's
going to select the buy stock tool. The
agent is going to send, uh, I love
Wi-Fi. It's my favorite thing. Um let's
see if there isn't a way around. Um I
can just sort of talk through this at a
high level. We'll take a look at um this
piece of our demo. So um what would have
you know ideally happened is we would
execute that trade because we have
bootstrapped our middleware inside of
this application. It would prompt me to
log in and once I logged in then the
agent would have tokens to use on my
behalf as a user. That would then
execute a trade. It's not actually
executing a trade. I have like a local
trade service running. So, you're not
missing many highlights, don't worry.
Um, and then once the trade um or once I
authenticated, then SIBO would
immediately dispatch a notification to
Odd Zero's back end and it would blow up
my phone and I would get a little
notification that's like, hey, would you
like to approve and authorize this
trade? One nice thing about the
notification that I get is it's not just
going to tell me, hey, something
happened. Would you like to approve it?
And I'm just going to be left
generically in the middle of the ether
trying to figure out where this
notification came from. It's actually
going to say this agent tried to do this
action, which in this case is purchasing
10 shares of something on your behalf.
Would you like to approve that
downstream flow? And then I have the
autonomy as an end user to to determine
whether or not I'm going to advance that
flow or cancel that flow. U one other
thing that I would have shown is once
I've authenticated the agent to act on
my behalf, subsequent trades no longer
need me um in the loop outside of the
SIBO flow. So once I've authentic or
yeah, once I've authenticated in the
authorization flow is then just
dispatched to SIBO, which is pretty
cool. Um, so going back to my notes, let
me see how many things that I missed. A
bunch of things, but that's okay. Um, so
in summary, we saw well kind of I talked
through how an agent can identify and
act on behalf of a specific user, how to
store and access credentials securely,
um, and how to use SIBA to get explicit
user approval for high-risisk actions
like trading without a browser to be
required. Um, so these patterns are
live. Um, they exist in defined
standards like OIDC, SIBA, um, rich
authorization requests, ozero, um,
developer previews have like, um,
attempts at a lot of these things or
actual production versions of a lot of
these things. So I'd encourage you guys
to check some of those things out. Um,
and some of these are GA like our, uh,
SA I believe is GA or at least in early
access um, inside of our platform. So
that's pretty cool. Um, thanks. That's,
uh, my demo. All right. So just moving
back here, if you go to the next slide.
Cool.
As Cam was saying, like we're trying to
make this easier for for developers. Um,
the standards are great. It means you're
not reinventing things over and over
again, but there's still a lot of
building blocks that you would have to
build. The Ozuro, other platforms have
similar things, but we're we're trying
to wrap this all up in a nice experience
for developers. So, the async user
confirmation with SBA is like a very key
component here. uh as well as calling
APIs on BAP users, things like token
exchange and token vault as well as fine
grain authorization for rag. You don't
have to use our platform for this. We
have open FGA that can snap into this
type of thing as well. Um and user
authentication and authorization
generally is is something that we do we
think deeply about. And with that,
here's what you can take with you.
There's a nice QR code and we'd love to
talk to anyone who's struggling with
these challenges, what you've hit uh in
your in your in your day-to-day life.
Just come talk to us after the talk. Um
I'm I'm also part of the open MCP spec
uh driving some of those discussion as
well. We're very interested in improving
that for everybody. So it's not just
about Ozero working with other um open
source libraries like MCP O which is
another great thing. So very deeply
interested in this space. Thanks. Thank
you.